when do we do the we're still here chant
as just as on behalf of the Rich Eisen
show tomorrow tomorrow we got a great
guest list we'll be letting you know
that later on this hour Shaquille
O'Neal's gonna stop by Ernie Johnson was
already here Kenny Smith's on tomorrow's
show we're literally down the hall from
the inside the NBA said we've been over
enjoying our time here in the Honda
studio area on the campus of Turner at
the Super Bowl Super Bowl 53 I turn to
my left and I see a man who I'm gonna be
in a meeting room within 90 minutes from
now for the eight and a half hour in my
marriage eight and a half NFL gameday
morning edition of Super Bowl talk good
to see you Steve Mary everybody look at
this audience they love their mood you
recruit these guys like last night or
this morning or yes pulled them right
off the street say you've got to see
Steve Mariucci and they said absolutely
well this is fun
thanks for having me on of course good
to see you what do you what do you been
doing on your soon mister guy did you do
TV today a little bit I didn't radio row
and all that stuff you know and just
kind of do you don't have to suit up for
radio idols I taped a couple things but
what are you ready Alan well do you have
a garage sale I want to buy that sweater
[Laughter]
I like it Kuji but I like it now what
what did they I don't want to give away
too much of my pardon my take that's the
question that big cat asked me under the
on the bars
pardon my takers after the Super Bowl
right they did ask you how much money
you spend a year on dad sweaters yeah
what's my budget for dad sweaters mr.
Rogers yeah you know and my answer can't
be this is a this is expensive stuff
that's not garage sales stuff Steve this
is this is the finest of Dan Marino wool
yeah I like it it was a compliment
I can't get it I'm in the tank right now
I'm in the tank you put me in the tank
with the sweater stuff how's your week
been going though bob is here
you check long its assets been great
been doing the shows
now I'm gonna start turning the page to
my dual role of the NFL Network gameday
morning host we've got our more how long
do you think this meetings gonna be so
on an 8 and a half hour show yeah
well it's got to be two and a half hours
three hours yeah and then we gonna do
some radio for Kurt Warner Kurt Warner I
mean and because Kurt's got a face for
radio so we're gonna do help him out
yeah all right yeah we're do something
or do that he's gonna do the game again
I know he's calling the Super Bowl yeah
he was here Tuesday yeah what do you
thinks gonna happen Sunday I have no
idea okay I was like laughs it's like
coming on like last week you know with
the final four
I love Final Fours you know whether it's
college basketball or pro football right
because of your best man at your wedding
yeah he is it turned 64 yesterday was it
really his birthday yeah anyway um
Purdue got him the other day
I know you probably texted them and
heckled them I didn't do any such thing
because we all know it just doesn't
matter till the Big Ten championship
which is when I will text and heckle I'm
going out there to Chicago you want to
go no to the Big Ten no tournament by
the way is it is this even cold too cold
for you what's happening in the Midwest
even for you
so 57 below in Chicago windchill you
know schools are canceled but usually a
canceled school because of snow days but
not cold days but that's football
weather to you you'd plan a picnic where
I'm from 57 so you don't have any idea
of what's gonna happen and so Sunday's
you think about it even you think about
it those games last championship weekend
they all go in overtime and just say
it's hard to predict a winner rise
there's so many good team there were
probably six or eight teams that were
good enough to get to this Super Bowl
regular I would hire you yes which is
good the league wants that the league
wants some parity at the top anyway and
try to raise up the bottom and I think
that's happening with Cleveland and but
all of the games that Brady has been in
in the Super Bowl and there have been
many all five of his wins are come from
behind win game-winning drives to win
the game and all of his losses are game
winning drives by Eli Manning or foals
last year you know what I mean they're
all close this is coming down to the
last Drive so you don't even have to
watch the
half just show up and watch the second
half because it's gonna be determined in
the last five minutes I don't know
that's how it's been it's turned into an
NBA game is what you're saying yeah it's
unbelievable and so that that adds to
the drama I always like to watch the
injury report it looks like pretty
pretty much the team you know what and I
the only guy that I'm concerned about
we're going to talk about it no it's not
it's yeah when did he get hurt he kicked
them I know he picked it from literally
half court as you like to call it you
know and and and he's hurt but his plant
leg was in a boot all week but that's
not good I'm worried about Gurley they
say he's not hurt you know what
he scored I watched that game again the
other night which one which good the
Rams in the Saints and in Girly's not
playing much he's in there you know more
than you think you only had five touches
but he's past protecting when he's in
there he scored the touchdown right
before the half and I figured oh maybe
he's feeling all right now after a
couple of drop passes well third quarter
begins at CJ Anderson for the next two
drives it was bizarre and Gurley wasn't
well he was riding a bike at one point
he was a generic bike it's my experience
if a guy is a little bit hurt yes they
want to play there in your face put me
back in you know what I mean and that
wasn't the case for him he was mellow he
was okay with it and so it seems to me
that he's hurt and he's concerned about
his knee so you know and how smart was
less need to pick up CJ I'm telling you
man that is a well I mean it's lesson
did you see he and Carol last night I
did yeah I did had dinner with the
general manager and his lovely wife
Carol I've known forever back in the day
from the SPN we launched the NFL Network
together and and there you know it the
Rams are I mean to say they're ready I
mean they were not breaking any any news
everybody can't wait to play the game
right now
I know ready to go but I mean what
lesson he did with CJ Anderson Dante
Fowler was the acquisition midseason and
he was the one who created the pressure
on Brees that led to the interception in
overtime obviously and AMA can sue and
Aqib to leave and Marcus Peters and then
Brandon cooks not only acquired but paid
the Gurley not only paid Aaron
Donald paid everybody's happy and
everybody's ready yeah and and that
offensive line is dynamite but the
Patriots one is to it really is a
terrific matchup it is really it is and
I'm glad we're not talking about the
Saints call non call and although we
could if you want to come but it is a
good matchup in that Rams team probably
in Patriot fans yeah there's my night
like this but I think the Rams have the
better roster from top to bottom drop
choices on their defense alone I mean
this team is stacked and not to mention
the guys they have on offense to they're
stacked with great player I don't know
how les needs affording all of these
good players you know we can't keep them
all forever but I know this is their
window well it helps to have golf in his
first contract it's imperative that you
have a right quarterback with a training
wheel contract you have to be able to
afford all these because when golf signs
a big one a lot of these guys are gone
but they got another year to do this but
you know to get all those guys on board
and and then just out of nowhere just go
get CJ Anderson are you kidding me right
now smart so Steve Mariucci here on the
Rich Eisen shown he's a perfect guy to
to talk about Tom Brady with since he
was the one who drafted Giovanni
Giovanni Camozzi in front of him and I
didn't know anything about him being a
goat farmer I really didn't at the time
so it was you and Bill Walsh who did it
it wasn't just you right who drafted car
mozzie now you didn't have even Brady on
the board you don't even have him on the
board on the board when you went with
car mazi do I have to go through this
again
yes what makes you think I just did this
in radio row so so here's what happened
with Tom Brady coming I Kurt Warner
didn't get drafted either nobody drafted
the guy no but you cut him yes we cut
him because he wasn't ready so so
hormones just taking elves right now so
here's the deal rich it's the way we
love each other so yeah
in Tom Brady I we had the same agent
dong-yi I didn't even know that now you
do and so but here's the deal when you
put your board up your draft board in
the National Football League
you you have to especially a quarterback
because that's the crapshoot call him
right you don't know but there are
different categories of quarterbacks we
had a guy named Steve Young I don't you
ever heard of him all right and he was
an athlete rich he was four or five they
were gonna move him the corner at BYU no
and then they said give me one more
chance and then they kept him at
quarterback he was that type of an
athlete and so and he wasn't ready to be
done yet so we were gonna get a young
guy a young athlete mole demerit
whatever and so Tom Brady was in a
category of the drop back quarterbacks
he was in this category we weren't
looking at that category we were looking
at the athletic quarterback geo car mazi
maybe because he was Italian I liked him
I don't know but he was a but he was a
Rhodes Scholar he was a 4/7 guy he was
point guard on the basketball team he
was in that athletic category and and so
we felt hey well maybe we're arrogant
guys we can coach him up and mold him
into a West Coast offensive kind of a
guy that's all and everybody passed on
Tom Brady as you know I know and I in
without everyone but not in soon what
you're saying but but Tom went to the
Harvard of the Midwest
let me tell Tom wasn't too much slower
than then the goat than the goat farmer
you know though this Shepherd or
whatever you want to call him I mean
what do you mean he's Tom God loved him
he still has the slowest 40 time of
quarterbacks in the combine ever okay
so he's not fast so much for the 40 time
at quarterback right but speaking of the
Harvard of the Midwest that's a misnomer
all right let me ask you a question okay
which school which university yes sir of
higher learning yes has the most
quarterbacks to appear in the Superbowl
let's open that up to the audience what
you know what that is yeah do is the one
that you you coached at Cal Berkeley
twice Cal has five quarterbacks that
made it to this game
can you name him Doug got oh I've got
golf
thank you Aaron Rodgers yep Vince
Ferragamo yes
damn it now I'm beginning as Warren
Beatty who are the other two Joe Kapp
Wow
when did he play in the Super Bowl for
the Vikings okay correct and and Craig
Morton okay five and I think the next
best is three so why did I say that I
have no idea CJ CJ Anderson's from Cal -
muchas was thrown out trivia I mean
throw a smoke screen up you know has he
draft Brady are we going to a break you
got something else I'm I'm having a
rough time this week as I did something
that I'm gonna regret what what when did
you come in I came in on Sunday you
Sunday came in Monday I'm a professional
was so what Tuesday I did something that
I'm I'm gonna regret and I hope my wife
doesn't find out about it what do you
eat Gail's gonna be pissed
what did you eat tattoo what is it gonna
embarrass the family - what is it I did
a rap video
[Music]
[Laughter]
so oh we do a lot of stupid things on
the show right so last year what did we
do
Irv and I America's favorite Odd Couple
you and I sweet went ice fishing alright
I wore that grumpy old men uniform and
he wore his fur coat and then we went to
well we went to Fort Irwin with the
military guys that was awesome shootin
right and then we then what Martian
aligned with the NASA all right that's
right okay so mr. so they they wanted to
do something in Atlanta right so do so
so when we get there's like alright
you're gonna do a rap video I don't know
I'm not gonna do a rap video and Monday
we record it over there where they do
Ludacris and everybody else over there
is this big-time studio Bob Whitfield
from Stanford owns the place
so this is part of game day morning oh
yeah my god my wife doesn't see it
because she will not be there when I get
well as you know we try to get new to
help us get Andy Reid in a little dickie
video called times yours that we want
yeah we wanted to do that the rapper
Andy as you know he said good good to
see a mooch who's in the rap video with
ya like who else well a little guy in at
24 years old named Keats and he wrote
the song he did the thing he does I told
her is a cow that's our producer I go
I'm not rapping I ain't doing this I
quit I'm not rapping and and and so he
cancelled the show and they already
rented the studio okay so I okay if we
have to do it then I'm gonna be the
producer I'm not the rapper well they
got me rapping a little bit
they've got you gotta watch our show on
Sunday fantastic all right I can't wait
to hear more our show meeting love you
mooch thank you coming by
see ya the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience